the number of women murdered or missing
in northern Mexico has risen by almost
40 percent in the past five years the
situation has pushed one woman the city
of Monterey to launch an exclusively
female taxi service here's her story my
name is
Gonzalez founder of gross taxi Monterey
a family-owned Enterprise we offer
transport services for girls and women
and guarantee they get to their
destination safely
on our first weekend we started trending
and we were shared more than 42 000
times that made me very happy but at the
same time it got us thinking why such a
reaction it means that there's a vacuum
in our community that women are scared
foreign
[Applause]
that's what made us start this service
the fear of how unprotected we women of
any age are in our community
[Music]
we have more than 3 000 clients on
WhatsApp our other Social Network
accounts are also full we can't handle
any more requests
many girls tell us why they chose us
some were harassed mistreated even
sexually abused by a driver they are
terrified of using any service with male
drivers
we think that whatever a girl is doing
on the street she shouldn't feel
threatened or in danger
the business is called girls Taxi
it will always remind me of Dulce
Celeste my daughter
I founded it for her I went a female
driven Cab in every corner of the world
so she can feel safe